la carte de l'ukraine avec intégré donc
la crimée sur le maillot et craignent un
le foot un terrain de géopolitique on en
parle avec pierre laurin journaliste
écrivain spécialiste de l'ex urss et
auteur du livre l'ukraine une histoire
entre deux destins aux éditions
bartillat qui vient d'être réédité
bonsoir pierre laurin merci d'être avec
nous sur arte france ce soir pourquoi
l'ukraine agit-elle de la sorte
maintenant kiev utilise certes le foot
pour faire pression mais on sait qu'il
ya la rencontre poutine maiden à genève
le 16 juin
oui effectivement je crois que l'ukraine
de toute façon saisi toutes les
opportunités pour faire parler d'elle
pour faire parler du conflit pour faire
parler la crimée et pour essayer de
ramener vers elle
les soutiens occidentaux qui en ce
moment semble lui faire plutôt défaut
parce que les occidentaux et en
particulier les états unis donnent
effectivement beaucoup d'importance à
l'ukraine dans les paroles mais dans les
actions
c'est beaucoup moins flagrant et c'est
encore pire du point de vue de l'union
européenne en particulier la france et
l'allemagne qui sont des médiateurs dans
le groupe ou format normandie sont très
sympathisants à l'égard de l'ukraine
mais ne font pas grand chose pour faire
avancer le
le conflit enfin la résolution du
conflit justement est ce que vous
comprenez la réaction la décision de
l'uefa qui accepte en ce maillot est-ce
que c'est pas un peu paradoxal sachant
que lors du tirage au sort par exemple
l'uefa a fait exprès de mettre la russie
et l'ukraine dans deux chapeaux
différentes pour ne pas que les deux
nations s'affrontent sur la pelouse 1 là
je veux dire oh je crois que il était
difficile pour les autorités du football
de refuser ce maillot dans le sens où
techniquement il n'y a pas grand chose à
redire c'est vrai que la carte de
l'ukraine représente également la crimée
mais c'est le cas de descartes qui sont
édités en ukraine mais également dans
d'autres pays occidentaux
il n'y a aucun pays occidental
aujourd'hui qui représente l'ukraine
sans la crimée c'est lorsque ça arrive
c'est arrivé à plusieurs reprises en
revanche fait machine arrière on crie au
scandale
donc là il n'y a pas de problème les
slogans question c'est vrai que ils sont
connotés historiquement parce que cela
fait référence à une période vraiment
très sombre de l'histoire de l'ukraine
mais gloire à l'ukraine
gloire aux héros bien dans le contexte
actuel c'est une marque de patriotisme
c'est on peut pas réellement éliminer ou
décider qu'un maillot n'est pas
acceptable à cause de cela donc c'est
très différent
comment est-ce qu'il faut alors les
épaules comment est-ce qu'il faut alors
interpréter les réserves de moscou à
bord les réserves d'eau douce qu elles
sont légitimes
la crimée est un territoire russe depuis
depuis le rattachement il était déjà
territoire ruche ce jusqu'en 1954 donc
pour pour moscou c'est c'est vraiment
une ligne à ne pas franchir
quant au slogan qui date effectivement
de 1940 41 et de l'armée
insurrectionnelle ukrainienne
il n'y a que les russes finalement qui
sont qui peuvent aujourd'hui dénoncer
cela parce que c'est une période de
l'histoire que les occidentaux ne
veulent pas voir si vous vous voyez les
choses aujourd'hui
il suffit qu'il y ait un néonazi quelque
part en europe pour que tout le monde
pousse les hauts cris mais qu'il y ait
des néo nazis en ukraine
on passe sous silence parce que eh bien
il ne faut pas
comment dirais-je fâcher les ukrainiens
qui sont en conflit avec le démon
actuelle l'ennemi que l'europe et les
états unis ont décidé de se créer qui
est la russie est une réaction
aujourd'hui celle de dmitro coup les
bassesses chef de la diplomatie
ukrainienne je cite à tous ceux qui
commencent à le critiquer et qui ne
supporte pas de voir nos frontières
reconnues internationalement ou le salon
officiel de notre état je répondrai
qu'une seule chose nous ne permettrons à
personne d'insulter nos symboles
nationaux quelle est votre analyse est
ce qu'on va vers une nouvelle escalade
verbale mais l'escaladé verbale n'a
jamais cessé ce qui est important c'est
que l'escaladé militaire c'est si ça
fait important escalade verbale elle va
continuer parce que c'est la seule arme
que l'ukraine dont l'ukraine dispose
pour continuer à faire en sorte que les
occidentaux soutiennent sa cause
or les occidentaux ne sont pas du tout
disposé à aller plus loin car soutien
verbal
un soutien qui irait plus loin c'est
quoi c'est engager des hostilités
militaires soutenir l'ukraine dans
l'engagement d'hostilité envers les
républiques de lougansk et des données
est ce que dans le dôme bars et
éventuellement contre la fédération de
lui de russie en crimée or ça aucun pays
occidental n'est disposé à aller aussi
loin
donc tout reste dans la phraséologie
dans les mots dans le duel de verbal
entre les uns et les autres et je crois
que
vous savez cette histoire de maillot va
très vite être oubliée parce que c'est
un épiphénomène
il y aura certainement lors des matches
des supporters ukrainiens qui
déploieront des banderoles il y aura
peut-être des mares des matches
pardon démarche en main en marge des
matches et ça s'arrête pas là et puis le
repas sera il est peu probable que la
russie et l'ukraine s'affrontent dans
les phases en justement là elles ne
peuvent pas s'affronter puisque lors du
tirage au sort l'uefa a fait en sorte
que ces deux équipes ne se rencontrent
pas en phase de poules
il ya d'ailleurs même dans les
compétitions de clubs
les clubs russes et ukrainiennes ne
peuvent pas s'affronter mais le sport
étant le support si la russie va en
finale si l'ukraine va en finale un
moment donné le tableau fait qu'on se
rencontre
normalement non puisque ce sont pas des
équipes favorites mais si elle venait à
se rencontrer comment ça se passerait en
tribunes entre vladimir poutine et
volodymyr zielinski lescure et des
délégations qui sera envoyé pour se
rencontrer pour discuter et se resterait
façade l'image de toute façon
actuellement il ya des délégations qui
se rencontrent et qu'ils discutent un le
maire c'est au niveau subalterne au
niveau supérieur il est question
d'organiser des rencontres
mais pour le moment ce n'est pas le cas
parce que chaque dirigeant aussi bien
l'animé routine que valve ordinaire et
lienz qui ont leur leur condition et
l'autre partie n'est pas prête à les
accepter à la dernière idée en en date
c'était une rencontre sous l'égide du
vatican à rome
mais bon c c'est un coup d'épée dans
l'eau
je crois que si il y à réellement un
match important c'est à dire les demi
finales où les finales se déroulent
entre les deux équipes
il y aura des délégations de part et
d'autre mais qui éviteront soigneusement
d'engager les pourparlers actuellement
les pourparlers ont lieu essentiellement
à minsk qui est là où se sont signés les
accords de 2014 et 2015 et où se
réunissent les délégations il y a très
peu de progrès mais tout de même depuis
peu les ukrainien kiev a accepté de
parler avec les délégations de
directement de donetsk est lougansk qui
depuis très longtemps ne réclame plus
l'indépendance contrairement à ce que
l'on affirme qu'ils veulent une
autonomie et la question aujourd'hui
c'est est ce que l'état ukrainien va
accepter de donner une autonomie même
légère à ces deux républiques
autoproclamées merci à pierre laurin mai